Donald Trump has been caught brutally
scamming his own followers again with a
Herschel Walker fundraising email where
everything is meant to look like the
money is for Herschel Walker but by
default only 10 of the donation actually
goes to Herschel Walker you have to see
this Trump is a known scammer Trump
scams his followers all the time what
Trump's cares about is what can you do
for me now what money can you give me
now Walker's campaign reports NBC News
tells Republicans to stop deceptive
fundraising in the Georgia runoff at
least four committees one of them
associated with Trump have kept 90
percent of contributions solicited for
Herschel Walker I will explain to you
how this works
uh an NBC also explains it
um The Campaign noticed the problem
Saturday
when former president Donald Trump save
America sent out an email that asked
prospective donors to quote contribute
any amount immediately to the official
Georgia runoff fundraising goal and
increase your impact by 1200 percent
but if donors didn't see a link that
said click here for details or to edit
allocation they wouldn't have noticed 90
of the contributions automatically go to
the orange Menace mango Mussolini Donald
Trump and only 10 percent go to Walker
um this is we could actually look at
this this is a video put together by
Jacob rabashkin and what you will see as
you click through here is that you check
that you want to contribute a certain
amount and then there is this link in
this case it was 250 dollars that was
clicked there's a link that says click
here for details or to edit allocation
if you just click the 250 or whatever
amount and then you look at the
allocation you will see that oh in this
case it's a thousand dollars of the
thousand dollar contribution
900 was automatically allocated to go
wait a second to Donald Trump
but this was a Herschel Walker
fundraising email and yet unless you
modify it
only 10 of the donation goes to Herschel
Walker NBC news reports that after this
was highlighted
Trump's committee changed it to a 50-50
split a 50 50 split
this is
um not unique to Herschel Walker NBC
news reports that at least originally in
some JD Vance fundraising emails and Ted
Bud fundraising emails it was initially
also 90 10. subsequently some of those
were changed it's the final grift or
maybe not the real final grift may be
running for president again we just
don't know we'll find out tonight or
maybe we won't find out tonight but this
is what Donald Trump does and as I've
told you before
Trump doesn't like his followers Trump
doesn't respect his followers we all
know when we think about it Donald Trump
was a rich kid from New York City who
spent his life
insulating and isolating himself from
the very people who now are his
supporters
sure to some degree he probably sees
them favorably to the extent that they
support him but we've seen very quickly
when there isn't anything for them to
vote for you for or for them to donate
to you for you flush them 10 or 15 times
Trump cares about his supporters if they
might vote for him for something or if
they might donate money and he is now
bilking them even more Trump's plane has
been repainted and refreshed and uh
renovated and fixed up so that now it is
flying him to rallies once again
uh these people who support him should
say wait a second we donated all this
money he became president he didn't do
any of the stuff he said he was going to
do didn't do the health care plan I
still have no health care I have
terrible Health Care he didn't build the
wall he didn't fix trade he didn't do
any of those things then he asked me for
more money
he lost in 2020. then he asked me for
more money and now he shows up making
terrible endorsements for people that
end up losing in 2022 and shows up in a
new plane did I pay for that plane have
I been scammed Again by this guy but
that is not the way they think it
through that does not seem to occur to
them uh and we will find out very very
soon
whether he still has the political
cachet to continue fundraising into
2023. we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today the Senate will act this week
to codify same-sex marriage federally
they say they have the votes do they I
think they do we'll talk about what this
will mean Google is paying nearly 392
million dollars to settle a huge
location tracking case
I have uh some personal experience with
this which I will share on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad and
lastly even though Kevin McCarthy wants
to be the next speaker of the house if
Republicans indeed take control of the
House of Representatives
some Republicans are warning McCarthy
you don't have the votes to be the
Speaker of the House does he or doesn't
he and if not could he get them all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com use the
coupon code 24 starts now to get a
beautiful discount I'll see you then
check out our sponsor Shaker and Spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers the craft cocktail
experience to your door each monthly box
comes with three original recipes
created by world-class bartenders with
ingredients for 12 cocktails my favorite
is the blood and Sage it's part of the
Vodka based drinks it uses herbed Sage
syrup and blood orange Meyer lemon
ginger ale delicious refreshing I love
how Shaker and Spoon includes everything
you need the ingredients the
instructions right in the Box the recipe
is easy to follow the blood and Sage
made for a very relaxing fall afternoon
on the back deck a lot of fun with
Shaker and Spoon you don't need to seek
out hard to find cocktail ingredients or
buy full-size containers of things
you'll use once this is way more
convenient Shaker and Spoon introduces
you to spirits and flavor combinations
you may never have otherwise discovered
any it is a fantastic holiday gift give
the gift of an awesome experience Shaker
and Spoon giving you twenty dollars off
your first box go to shakerandspoon.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below